you're listening to episode 12
of storycast 21 i'm jane secker
on august the 4th 2020 a nation
struggling to cope with rising covet 19
infections
and crippled by an economic crisis
suffered a devastating disaster that was
to profoundly change the city
and the lives of its two million
inhabitants forever
among them a port worker and his family
this is
the beirut blast gassan's story
my name is zayn jafar
i'm a journalist i'm the middle east
news editor for sky news
i remember the day of august the 4th
2020
pretty vividly our office
and the flat that i lived in is based
right in the center of beirut
lebanon is in the grips of a really very
devastating
economic and political crisis lebanon
like
so many other countries around the world
was in the grips of a coronavirus
pandemic
and with that comes a huge amount of
political instability
i remember just looking out at the
balcony of our office
and seeing the kind of smoke on the
horizon it must have been three or four
hundred meters from
the port and thinking that maybe it was
an industrial
fire you know not really thinking much
of it
but actually in a hangar just a few
dozen meters away
this fertilizer this chemical one of the
most dangerous chemicals
and most combustible chemicals
imaginable thousands of tons of it was
right next door
i am ali hasbrodil i am from uh
the mount of lebanon my father is hassan
hassler
the head of the operation unit at the
grand salo
at the port
he switched his shift from the fifth
to the fourth because on the fifth
of august we have a feast
my name is tatsana hasudi
that week and we were going to a
monastery where we used to go
it was like a family ritual and
we would never miss it so he talked to
mom
around 5 30 pm asking her
that he needs a pillow and a blanket
since he will be working for 24 hours
supervising
[Music]
ali and tatiana's father was 60 years
old he'd been
a port worker for nearly 40 years
and he was i think pretty senior manager
working at the bay report
there was a huge amount of this
fertilizer this chemical that was
brought in it was confiscated it was
kept in a hangar at the port
but it was never disposed of or treated
properly
and left in the port for years ammonium
nitrate
it's highly flammable it's highly
combustible and it's incredibly
dangerous
[Music]
as the day went on this sort of massive
fire was growing and actually because
it was happening at the port it meant
that really across beirut
if you were high enough you'd be able to
see this this huge
plume of smoke that was emanating from
the port
and i was making myself some some dinner
and i got a call from a colleague of
mine at sky
who was just asking me about the general
situation in lebanon
just after christmas 50 of this country
were below the poverty line this is a
city of 2 million people
more than half of the city has been
lebanon for
the best part of a year
had been basically going through this
incredibly
tumultuous period of its history
[Music]
there have been protests across the
country
[Music]
and the epicenter of those protests were
right in the centre of downtown beirut
and this colleague was very keen to know
whether there was perhaps
you know scope to do some stories so i
was talking her through
the general situation in the country and
what was happening
[Music]
and at that moment whilst i was on the
phone i just felt the
ground start to shake
and within a split second there was you
know this
incredible noise
i remember sort of being on the floor
and i could hear
the correspondent who i've been talking
to still
asking me questions on the phone and she
actually said have you dropped the phone
down the toilet
because of the noise because of the sort
of the shock waves
and i just in a sort of split second
picked up the phone and said to i've got
to call you back
there's been a massive explosion
i was working
remotely 40 kilometers
away from the port of baywood
i heard the first explosion
then the second a bigger one
the first thought that came into my mind
is that we are having an israeli strike
in baroque mountain next to us
they used to have strikes on the
telecommunication
antennas there however
five minutes later it was really clear
that there have been some sort of
explosion
in support of baywood
[Music]
we live in cinephil in the suburbs of
beirut
our house was severely damaged by the
blast
we had glass all over the place on our
beds
on our sofas actually first we
thought it was an earthquake
my sister came with her kids and
we turned on the tv the kids were crying
we were trying to concentrate to see
what happened
i called them on the landline and i
asked about my father
we tried calling his phone number his
private number
his work number and we didn't get an
answer
i just went to the to my car and
directly heading i was heading to beirut
i thought myself i have to be open
of what will be happening
my phone didn't stop ringing asking
about my father and i was telling them
my father is there we don't know
any clue of the road i was
asking myself would i go to the poor
or to my family good evening we
start tonight with breaking news there's
been a large explosion in the lebanese
capital beirut it's not known what
caused the blast which centered
on the port area of the city casualties
have been reported
i remember walking out of the apartment
onto a sort of side street that led to
the main square
everything around me was was totally
destroyed
there felt like this kind of orange hue
across the city this kind of
thick orange sort of smog dust
smoke
the sounds of the sirens were incessant
ambulances fire trucks police sirens
were constant i mean constant
the crunching of glass everywhere you
walked
i thought it may have been a car bomb or
some kind of farm or explosion
and i remember at that point is when i
first noticed this this kind of black
plume of smoke towards the port
i started to walk towards it
let's speak to our middle east editor
zayn jaffar who is in
beirut so zayn tell me what you uh saw
and heard you could hear an explosion
and
uh everything is flat where i am and in
the apartment block no importantly that
i'm in
uh has essentially been blown out the
windows flats totally leveled
people walking out on the streets
covered in blood with plastic bags full
of their possessions
it was an absolute scene of real horror
fact that the very early reports the
nightingale from lebanese feature do
seem to suggest
this was a very severe industrial
accident there were a lot of people who
were
really desperately trying to find and
locate their loved ones people who had
worked near or worked in the court at
the time of the explosion
at first i posted on twitter that we
cannot
find my dad and people started calling
us
tatiana was was on social media
asking questions if anyone had any
information
after several hours i posted his picture
and
what was he wearing probably that day
so we've divided ourselves into teams to
go to hospital
and to to really decide to figure out
what was the situation there my father
would be at the operation room or he
might
have went somewhere and took a snack
let's say we spent
all the night just moving around the
hospital
asking trying to match pictures
they are well over 3 000 people injured
and at least 50 people killed and it was
the next afternoon around lunchtime that
we've gone over to ellie and tatiana's
house
in the suburbs of beirut the outskirts
of beirut and met them
and their family but the authorities
have made it clear we can expect those
numbers to rise in the coming hours i
have slept for an hour
trying to communicate with the friends
of mine
to see what is happening at the port
at the zone where the blast took place
where my father
is with his colleagues
and nothing was happening very many
thing
was happening the idea
and the kind of understanding of this
being an explosion caused by
material that was stored in the port had
become i think
a lot more prevalent and there was real
anger and resentment and frustration
growing in building
at that reality
these protests firstly have been going
on now
for three days saturday the city erupted
convulsing with fury
at a government which has allowed
thousands of tons of ammonium nitrate to
be negligently stored
in terms of the cause of this blast this
may have been
explosive material that was being held
confiscated material
that may have ignited and caused this
explosion but that the security forces
are still
investigating i have to say after two
weeks
on the 18th of august i have received
the only call from an official asking me
to come to rafael hariri
hospital because the dna
my dna match was a body dna
and it was confirmed that it was my
father's
body we've waited 14 days
to know the destiny of my father they
didn't care
to have such an explosive material
located unprotected
in this place they weren't considering
the human fact
about governing a country
my father was our rock so
he would like be there always whenever
wherever
he wanted to spend as much time as he
can with me
he wanted me to prove myself before
getting married
he always believed in my capacities
and in me being a strong independent
woman
we start with breaking news this
afternoon from lebanon where the prime
minister hassan
diab is expected to stand down shortly
the rest of his government has already
resigned following mounting anger in the
country
over the devastating explosion in favor
of this good lifespan
ali and tatiana the hasruti family
are amongst many hundreds of families in
lebanon who to this day
refuse to give up and refuse to back
down in the demands for justice
they feel that it's their right and it
is their right to
to know why their loved ones were taken
away from them
in such a horrific manner
justice is my vision is my mission to do
[Music]
i cannot accept that another young girl
would be deprived of her father of his
affection and of his love
because of their corruption and
selfishness i cannot accept that
and i'm gonna work as
as hard as i can to ensure that justice
is going to be served
lebanon as a country was already
struggling so much
before the events of august the 4th
before that explosion
but the explosion really tipped it over
because what happened after the beirut
blast
i think changed people's lives forever
for that explosion to have happened
in the center of a capital city with so
many
normal ordinary innocent people trying
to just live their lives as best as they
can
in the grips of a crisis for that to
have happened
i think took that sense of
protection or that sense of security
away
and what it's left actually is a country
in
almost constant mourning is an economy
that has been totally shattered
it's people bereft and unable to survive
because they've lost
loved ones because they've lost their
support system because they've lost
their homes and their livelihoods
they've lost their jobs
you consider the amount of destruction
you consider
more than 200 people killed thousands
injured billions of pounds worth of
damage done
just how so many months afterwards there
still hasn't been
serious accountability and justice is
just unfathomable it was
one of my greatest fear to lose my
father because we are a
very close family and
what i said in his family
that loved or don't die and
we've experienced love with her and
this love will be born in us and
way bigger and i'm better
as a trend in history that
everything will get better and
we're going to a world with more justice
less
less harder
as of august 2021 the number of recorded
deaths from the beirut explosion
stands at 211 with more than 6 000
injured justice campaigners say
authorities continue to obstruct their
efforts to bring about a proper
investigation into the disaster the
beirut blast
kazan's story was written and produced
by rob mulhern
with zane jafar for more information log
on to skynews.com
forward slash storycast 21
storycast 21 will now take a break for
august
the series resumes in september starting
with an extended episode
to mark the 20th anniversary of the 9 11
attacks
i arrived in new york suitcase under one
arm
dog under the other arm i couldn't
believe that not only was i working
there but i was working in the world
trade center
head office was on the 84th floor of two
world trade center
which was the south tower